oh my god i am so sorry can i get you a
drink ah that's so kind of you to offer
i'll take five shots of whiskey and two
jager bombs what are you having
same
thing
[Music]
i'm brody by the way
marvin
i haven't seen you around you're a
tourist nah i've been in baltimore for
medical
rude of you to be hot and smart well
actually i dropped out i just had this
feeling of why like why am i here
reading about liver tissue for the next
10 years i [ __ ] hate hospitals
hot smart and afraid of commitment every
gay man's tight
but not every gay man
my ex replaced me with ficus
[ __ ] off with your problems and not your
therapist wait what i was flirting with
you you dick
yes sorry of course he'll gross stop
fine
and yes
i have a huge dick
and yes if [ __ ] work
[Music]
okay we need to tell him
[ __ ] are you insane
that is a terrible idea he's staying
with me i can't do the lying thing
anymore i've spent too much of my life
keeping secrets we are not a secret
babe
this isn't a thing
[Music]
[Applause]
so
when do we get to meet your new
boyfriend
whatever
[Music]
what's up his butt
who cares
you're back oh let's go catch up
[Music]
[Music]